ما الذي يعنيه طلب فتوى من محكمه العدل
الدوليه محكمه العدل الدوليه واضافه
لدورها في فضل النزاعات القانونيه تمتلك
سلطه اصدار فتاوى او ابداء الراي بشان
مسائل قانونيه
لكن الطلبه يجب ان يصدر عن الجمعيه العامه
للامم المتحده او مجلس الامن الدولي او اي
هيئه اخرى ضمن الامم المتحده يؤذن لها
توجيه مثل هذا الطلب بمعنى ان الدول لا
يمكنها طلب الفتوى مباشره من المحكمه
[موسيقى]
الفتوى او الراي عاده غير ملزم من الناحيه
القانونيه لهيئه الامم المتحده فهو مجرد
فتوى قضائيه تتمثل بعرض الراي القانوني من
جانب المحكمه على الجمعيه العامه للامم
المتحده
لكن اهميتها تنبع من انها صادره من اعلى
جهه قضائيه دوليه تتكون من قضاه ينتمون
الى اغلب النظم القانونيه في العالم
رغم عظمي الزاميتها فان الفتوى قد يترتب
عليها تداعيات دبلوماسيه دوليه وبان تشكل
مرجعيه بوصفها عرضا لموقف القانون الدولي
من هذه المساله ومن شانها ان تعرض قاده
الاحتلال لخطر الملاحقه القانونيه
[موسيقى]